retrouver l'esprit versailles et à
travers cinq produits
ce coffret vendu 35 euros à l'office du
tourisme renferme des articles gourmands
comme cette préparation pour fondant au
chocolat mais aussi des accessoires
valeur marchande 70 euros on répond à un
double objectif
d'abord le versailles et qui veut partir
à l'étranger est exportée on peut
finalement de sa ville et puis le
touriste qui veut partir avec un
souvenir et qui gardera autre chose
peut-être que versailles ville
d'histoire mais aussi versailles ville
artisanale et savoir faire
parmi les produits proposés ce
porte-clés en cuir et bois frappé du nom
de la cité royale
un objet durable dans le temps son
créateur damien béal est installé depuis
deux ans et demi à versailles
il ya plein de gens qui peuvent ne pas
connaître tous les produits locaux at le
made in versailles à des produits qui
sont fabriqués à depuis très longtemps
dans la ville le fait d'avoir cette box
avec différents produits et puis un
catalogue qui permet aussi de retrouver
d'autres adresses des lieux pour manger
des lieux à visiter des choses comme ça
je voudrais c'est bien chaque créateur
dispose de sa fiche explicative lancé au
début du mois de mai la sélection
versailles est destiné à évoluer qui est
intéressant avec cette phase test c'est
qu'on va aussi recueillir les avis pour
évoluer
puis faire évoluer le produit en
fonction des attentes d'autres artisans
versailles et pourront se retrouver
prochainement dans cette petite boîte à
l'esprit chic et les gants